an identity matrix is one of the most
important matrices we will look at in
the topic of matrices
what does identity mean in mathematics
it means getting the same answer as the
original number let me give you a couple
of examples what x 3 will give us 3 yes
what multiplied by this number gives us
the same number it's 1 & 3 multiplied by
what will give us 3 1 again multiplying
any number with 1 gives us that same
number the number 1 is called the
multiplicative identity no matter what
number it is multiplied with it will
give us the same number so you can
probably guess what an identity matrix
is no matter which matrix it is
multiplied with it will give us the same
matrix a 2 by 2 identity matrix looks
like this and a 3 by 3 identity matrix
looks like this how can we define it it
is a square matrix which has all the
elements in the leading diagonal as one
and the rest of the elements as zero
leading diagonal elements equal 1 and
others are 0 let's say we have a square
matrix a matrix a multiplied by I will
give us matrix a some matrix multiplied
by I will give us that same matrix
weight we also know that matrices are
non commutative a times I gives us a but
does I times a also give us a yes I
times a will also give us a the identity
matrix when multiplied with any matrix
gives us that same matrix back it is
also called the unit matrix will this
always work for any square matrix if the
order of the identity matrix is same as
this one then yes it will always work
let's look at a matrix on a new page
this is matrix a we
to check if a x I gives us a this is a
and as this is a 2 by 2 matrix the
identity matrix will also be 2 by 2 it
will be 1 0 0 1 we need to check if this
product of two matrices gives us matrix
a back is this product compatible the
order of both the matrices are 2 by 2 as
the second and the third numbers are
equal this product is compatible and the
order of the resulting product will
equal the first number by the 4th number
2 by 2 again so what will be the 1 1 8
element of the resulting matrix first
row times the first column 1 multiplied
by 1 plus 0 times 0 it will equal 1 for
the 1 2 element we multiply the first
row with the second column 1 multiplied
by 0 plus 0 times 1 it will equal 0 the
first two elements are the same as a
let's find the remaining two the 2 1 at
element will equal the second row
multiplied by the first column minus 2
multiplied by 1 plus 3 times 0 we get
minus 2 and the last element will be the
product of the second row and the second
column minus 2 x 0 plus 3 times 1 we get
3 that completes our matrix and we see
that the product a I gives us a matrix
which is equal to matrix a matrix a
multiplied by the identity matrix give
the matrix a back now we also need to
check if I times a gives us matrix a
this is the identity matrix and this is
matrix a pause the video and try to find
the product both matrices are two-by-two
matrices and hence this product is
compatible and the order of the
resulting matrix
we'll be two by two there will be four
elements in the resulting matrix the 1 1
8 element will be equal to the first row
times the first column 1 multiplied by 1
plus 0 times minus 2 it will equal 1 to
find the one to earth element we
multiply the first row with the second
column 1 multiplied by 0 plus 0 times 3
it will equal 0 the two 1s element will
equal the second row multiplied by the
first column 0 multiplied by 1 plus 1
times minus 2 we get minus 2 here and
the last element will be the product of
the second row and the second column 0 x
0 plus 1 times 3 we get 3 that completes
our matrix and we see that it is equal
to matrix a as well the orders of both
matrices are the same and the
corresponding elements are also equal if
I is the identity matrix then both a
times I and I times a will give us
matrix a